really interesting results so far at
labour as we've been talking about as
you've been covering uh really
celebrating those results in london just
have a look at the big grid there are
still a lot of very important seats
still to come still a lot of grey to be
filled in but just have a look down here
london that's the story that labour are
really going to want to focus on this
morning and some of the results have
been really remarkable when we start to
dig into the numbers of what's happened
so barnet
that council that we were just
discussing that actually went towards
the conservatives last time these seats
were elected in 2018 look 12 whole seats
that labor's taken from the
conservatives a real turn around there
westminster as well a council that has
never
been held by labour they've taken it
tonight from the conservatives 13 uh
whole seats that they took there and
really building on this picture of how
well labour is doing in london look up
49 seats and look the tories down 60.
must mention the liberal democrats as
well they are having a very very good
night indeed particularly in the capital
and this gives you a bit of a visual
representation of just how much of a
mountain labour have climbed in a place
like wandsworth just look at that vote
share over time going all the way back
to the 90s that big gap between the
conservatives and labor and just look
that crossover there that is what labour
will really be celebrating this morning
but nationally if we take a step back
things are a smidge more nuanced and
it's really important to say that
because labour have done very well in
london but if they want to win the next
general election they also need to be
doing well in places like bolton places
with a high labour vote places that
abandoned labour in that 2019 general
election now remember this set of
results these seats were last fought in
2018 so
no change for labor is actually really
sort of a return to that level of
support that they enjoyed before that
big collapse however they probably
wanted to be seeing a few more gains in
places like this if they want to really
build up that support look it was
actually the conservatives that gained a
seat there and i just want to show you
this this breaks down uh for us
the change in vote share in different
regions of the country for the different
parties so everything this side of the
line a loss in vote share and gains this
side and just look at what's happened to
the conservative voter in the south look
at those losses and it's remarkable
really because the south of course is
clearly the areas where the
conservatives would normally be able to
bank on support the beneficiaries
liberal democrats and this grey is
actually including the green party as
well they've done very well
not perfect for labor either look uh
they've gone down a bit in the north and
the midlands they would really want to
be picking up there i want to leave you
with one final thought this is the
overall gains and losses of seats
all over the country that we've seen so
far at this stage given the number of
councils we've had back a really
disastrous night for the conservatives
would have been losses of about 170 180
seats so it is not quite as bad as it
could be but that number 146 seats down
clearly not where boris johnson wanted
to be at this time this morning